>>♪♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE PRESIDENT WILL ADDRESS
SUPPORTERS IN LAKE CHARLES,
LOUISIANA.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THE
DEPARTURE OF HIS ACTING DHS
SECRETARY OF STATE.
A REMARKABLE RALLY LAST NIGHT
AND WE EXPECT ANOTHER ONE
TONIGHT.
IN THE MEANTIME, WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
A STORY WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS.
BY DAY, STEVE KERR IS THE COACH
OF THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
BASKETBALL TEAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN HIS SPARE TIME, KERR MOON
LIGHTS AS A POLITICAL PUNDIT AND
IS HAPPY TO SHARE HIS HOT TAKE
ON AMERICAN POLITICS.
HE IS LIKE A ONE MAN TWITTER.
THE PRESIDENT IS A RACIST HE
WILL SAY AND YOU HAVE TOO MANY
GUNS AND PEOPLE AROUND HIM
APPLAUD.
HE THINKS HE IS BRAVE FOR SAYING
THINGS THAT NOT A SINGLE PERSON
IN THEIR WORLD DISAGREES WITH.
IT'S NOT BRAVELY AT ALL.
IT'S COWARDICE.
SOMEONE ASKED STEVE KERR WHAT HE
THINKS OF THE GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA, THE LARGEST POLICE STATE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE HUMAN
RACE.
MAYBE BECAUSE THE NBA DOES A
GREAT DEAL OF BUSINESS IN CHINA,
KERR WAS FLUM OXED BY THE
QUESTION.
FASCISM OR DEMOCRACY.
I DON'T WANT TO WEIGH IN.
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
LAST NIGHT HE WAS ASKED AGAIN
ABOUT CHINA AND ANSWERED THE
QUESTION.
SURE, CHINA HAS PROBLEMS SO DOES
THE UNITED STATES.
CHINA SEND RELIGIOUS MINORITIES
TO CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND
EXECUTES POLITICAL PRISONS TO
SELL THEIR ORGANS BUT IN AMERICA
THEY SELL GUNS AT WAL-MART.
>> IT DOES NOT COME UP.
PEOPLE ASKING ME ABOUT IT.
NO.
NOR HAS OUR RECORD OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES COME UP EITHER.
PEOPLE IN CHINA DIDN'T ASK ME
ABOUT PEOPLE OWNING AR-15S AND
MOWING EACH OTHER DOWN IN A
MALL.
I WASN'T ASKED THAT QUESTION.
THE WORLD IS A COMPLEX PLACE.
THERE IS MORE GRAY THAN
BLACK-AND-WHITE.
>> Tucker: SOME THINGS ARE NOT
THAT GRAY LIKE PUTTING MUSLIMS
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
STEVE KERR AND THE NBA WERE MADE
FOR EACH OTHER.
THE NBA EPITOMIZES CAPITAL
RUTHLESSNESS UNDER THE GUISE OF
COMPASSION.
THEY EMPLOY KERR WHO IS THE
MODERN MINDLESS ELITE LEFT.
HE IS HAPPY TO TRASH HIS OWN
COUNTRY AND GIVES UP NOT ONE
THING IN RETURN.
HE RECEIVES ONLY ACCOLADES.
BUT WHEN REAL EVIL STARES HIM IN
THE FACE HE HAS NOTHING TO SAY.
REAL EVIL IS POWERFUL.
THERE ARE COSTS TO OPPOSING IT
AND REWARDS FOR ACCEPTING.
THE NBA COMMISSIONER ADAM SILVER
SAID THE NBA WILL STAND BY FREE
SPEECH NO MATTER WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES FROM CHINA.
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
SEVERAL NBA TEAMS ARE ON AN
EXHIBITION TOUR IN CHINA RIGHT
NOW.
THAT PRESENTS A AIR OPPORTUNITY.
-- RARE OPPORTUNITY.
SUPERSTAR NBA PLAYERS CAN SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT ABOUT CHINA'S
REGIME AND GET ATTENTION AND
AVOID CONSEQUENCES.
ARE YOU GOING TO PUT AN NBA
PLAYER IN JAIL?
NO, THEY HAD A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK REAL TRUTH
TO REAL POWER.
BUT THE NBA STOPPED THEM.
TODAY THE NBA ANNOUNCED THAT
NONE OF THE PLAYERS ON THE TOUR
IN CHINA WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THE MEDIA FOR THE REST OF THE
TRIP.
WOULDN'T WANT ANY USING THEIR
FREE SPEECH THE WRONG WAY AND
CRITICIZING THEIR CHINESE
MASTERS.
THE COACH OF THE SAN ANTONIO
SPURS SAID THE PRESIDENT BRINGS
OUT THE DARK SIDE OF HUMAN
BEING.
IN 2016 HE BRAGGED AS AN
AMERICAN HE COULD SPEAK HIS MIND
ON ANYTHING.
THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT WHAT IS HE USING THAT FREE
SPEECH FOR?
HE IS NOT USING IT AT ALL.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE NBA IN
CHINA WHICH IS THE CRITICAL
ISSUE, HE HAD NOTHING TO SAY.
HE BLASTED TRUMP FOR HANDLING
THE JAMAL KHASHOGGI
ASSASSINATION LAST YEAR.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
CHINA?
NOTHING.
WHY ANSWER THAT?
BECAUSE SAUDI ARABIA HAS A
SMALLER BELIEVE  -- BASKETBALL
MARKET.
WHERE IS DALLAS MAVERICKS OWNER
MARK CUBAN?
HE CAME ON THIS SHOW BUT SO FAR
HE HAS NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT
CHINA AND ITS CONTROL OVER THE
NBA.
THIS PROVES THE RULING CLASS IS
PHONEY.
THEY ARE WEAK AND PATHETIC.
THAT'S OBVIOUS NOW.
THEY TALK A BIG GAME ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS AND LECTURE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
THE THREAT TO YOU IS NOT RUSSIA